good evening everyone welcome to
statford on aen District Council
planning committee my name is councelor
Lewis Adam I'm your chairman for this
evening I'll start with some
housekeeping um there is no fire alarm
plan for this evening so if it does go
off please make an orderly exit and the
must point is the car park opposite the
Pu across the road uh where you can
check off your names uh please make sure
your phones are set to silent or turned
off so that they don't uh disrupt the
flow of the meeting uh this is a meeting
in public not a public meeting and only
those permitted to speak uh are
registered ahead of time um I'll call
you up at the right uh time and give you
further instructions then and for
information the uh meeting is being
filmed and broadcast on our website um
and for the record for future use I'll
now introduce our top table from
committee Services is Olivia Quinn US
list to this evening is Amy Shipley our
planning manager is Emily napia and our
planning officers are Victoria Kempton
and Sarah fety believe Emily you have a
statement
prepared thank you chair my role tonight
is to provide impartial advice to
committee members and to assist members
in their decision
taking thank you very much um okay then
we can move on to the first item which
is apologies for
absence chair we have apologies from
councelor Holmes and councelor Parry who
councelor littlewood is substituting
for thank you very much uh item two
disclosures of Interest any disclosures
from the
members doesn't look like there's
anything this evening very
good okay item three minutes um so this
is to confirm that the minutes of the
meeting held on the 8th of November are
an accurate record we've all had
opportunity to see them can I have
agreement agreed very good I'll sign
those in due course okay then we're
moving on to our planning applications
for the evening uh I'm going to jump in
with number uh item number five which is
application
23249 gleh house fossway ashorn the
reason for this being um brought to
committee uh has been withdrawn and so
that item is going to be delegated to
officers in line with the council
council's
procedures okay so we move on then to
item four which is application
23936 fairy wford Chase Benton Road
wford on a our presenting officer is
Victoria Kempton and when you're ready
take it
away good evening and thank you
chairman um so this application site is
identified by the black dot on the map
which is to the north of Welford
donaven this slide outlines the
application site in red which is
currently a caravan park within the park
there is one dwelling which is
conditioned for the use by a person
solely employed as a site
Warden the current application is
seeking to remove this condition from
the 2009 planning application with the
effect to allow for an UNR occupation of
the dwelling in terms of constraints the
site lies within the flood zone 3 where
the Riven a the river aen runs along the
southern boundary the solid red
rectangle shows the grade two listed
binton bridge and finally the site is
assess to be within the open Countryside
location being outside of the adopted
buap peria
boundary the existing wardens dwelling
is at the edge of the Caravan Park to
the east east of the site and is
accessed via track leading around the
North north of the site the green line
around the property shows the proposed
curtilage the officer's report discusses
the background of the justification to
remove the condition in detail but in
summary the main justification is that
the Caravans are no longer used for
seasonal holiday uses but are instead
permanently
occupied these are some photos with the
first photo showing the front elevation
of the dwelling with the wider caran
Park to the side and rear you can see
that the property is elevated with
garaging at ground floor
level these site photos illustrate the
surroundings with two recent Park Homes
additions to the South and open
Countryside to the Northeast the second
photo shows the access drive on the
approach to the
dwelling in summary there are a couple
of updates listed on the update sheet
the officer's recommendation is for
approval subject to finalization of a
section 106 agreement um and this
concludes my presentation thank you
chairman thank you very much Victoria
okay we now move on to our first Speaker
then who is councelor Neil Appleton from
wford on aan Parish
Council good evening counselor uh you've
got three minutes
um so it's just the button on the right
hand side um to turn the microphone on U
I'm happy to give you a 30 second um
warning before your 's up if you're
happy with
that lovely so as soon as you turn the
microphone on uh you take it away
Parish Council agreed with a case
officer that the building is not
suitable as an open market dwelling it
does not meet the requirements of
Stratford's policy as10 fails to meet
the requirements of Paris Council
policies H5 which is open Countryside
and H9
flooding condition two restricts
occupation to a
warden the reason given for this
condition to prevent unrestricted
occupation of the dwelling in accordance
with national guidance and advice this
National guidance and advice remains EXT
St and is reflected in local policy the
applicant should be encouraged to comply
the most practical solution is for the
building to revert to former
use the fallback to demolish the
building and replace it with a caravan
is presented as a fallback position the
applicant argues that this is less safe
than the dwelling which they argue is
more flood resilient Paris Council
therefore suggests that were this to
happen the applicant would be acting in
a wholly irresponsible
manner however the fallback argument is
flawed the number number of Caravans on
the site is not determined by the
presence or absence of the
dwelling the site enjoys the benefits of
a lawful development certificate which
specifically allows up to 60 Caravans
for year round occupation although the
LDC covers an area that encloses the
building it is quite specific about
Caravans hence the fallback does not
apply in principle the applicant May
position up to 60 Caravans around the
site it is not dependent upon the
building or more specifically upon
condition two that the applicant seeks
to
remove the applicant will have you
believe that they can place an unlimited
number of Caravans on the site this is
conjecture it is not covered by the LDC
and would be subject to planning
permission the warden the site is in
flood zone 3 the warden was Central to
the implementation of the original flood
evacuation plan on the site a new
evacuation plan has been produced as a
consequence of this planning application
it bypasses the need for a warden it
relies on text or email to Residents the
parish M Council maintained that these
alerts are not fit for purpose on a
highrisk site in flood zone 3 the enir
environment agency have a minimum
warning period of only two hours modern
phones have do not disturb features I
pity any Resident who fails to receive
an alert in the middle of the night and
in the morning finds themselves floating
down the
river the need for a warden goes beyond
flood evacuation planning comments from
residents suggest that the applicant has
a contractual obligation to provide a
Warden the applicant states that one is
not required this may be more wishful
thinking on the part of the of the um
applicant than actual reality on balance
the Paris Council remain unconvinced
that the warden is not
required the Paris Council maintain that
the safest and most practical way that
the applicant can comply with policy is
for the building to be occupied by a
warden if not it should revert to former
use if you have any questions please do
ask thank you for your time
thank you very much uh Council applon um
members do we have any questions for our
Paris councelor Council
pton thank you chair um can you confirm
if you're aware of I have two questions
by the way um any age restriction for
occupation of the
site minimum age I'm not aware of any
age restriction you mean in terms of the
people occupying them do they have to be
over 55 over 60 something like that uh
what you mean from the homes I'm not
aware of that um if there is a
restriction um but yes clarify that with
the agent we we do we are concerned that
evacuation of uh people saying a
wheelchair is could be could be
difficult and can you comment on mobile
phone coverage in the
area uh if you've got if you're on O2
you're okay I think but it can be a bit
patchy for some of the other
providers thank you any further
questions for Paris Council coun
Harvey mron councel Pi aart um two
questions uh one is uh you use the
phrase acting in an irresponsible Manner
and I didn't quite understand what you
were referring to I if you could
elucidate okay I can do yes um let me
just refer to my notes so the par the
applicant um has presented a position in
which um they say they can knock down
the dwelling and replace it with a
caravan which is at ground level um the
Caravans on this site are flood
resilient in the sense that they are
Tethered to their location and they are
on floats so that they can raise in the
event of a flood um
now in balancing whether or not it's
better to be in a raised dwelling on a
on a first floor or whether to be in a
floating Caravan the applicant or the
the planning um officer the planning
consultant sorry um suggests that it's
better to be in a fixed dwelling than it
is to be in a caravan and from that
perspective um they argue that they they
would prefer to have a fixed dwelling in
on the open market rather than using a a
park home Caravan um that's their
argument um and and if if you follow
that argument through to its conclusion
for them to knock the house down and
then replace it with a caravan would be
an irresponsible thing to do that's
really where I logic lies sorry that was
a bit rambling but that's my second
question the second question is I I I do
know the site I've walked around it
before um but I haven't got any sense of
the frequency of flooding have you got
any evidence or statistics or data that
we could refer to that that illustrates
the degree to which I don't have any
data to hand to be fair um but I can
tell you that in 2007 when we had the
massive flooding event then people were
being airlifted off
dislocation with the Coast Guard um
coming in and taking them off on
helicopters um I I know that we we had a
subsequent flooding flooding in 2011
2013 the road outside was inundated to a
depth of probably about a foot um and
that was not such a severe flooding
event at that time um but we are talking
about flood zone 3B this functional
flood plane that we're talking about
it's not a
uh it's not it's not a sort of rare
occurrence people in this who live here
expect to get their feet wet I think
that's a fair a fair
assessment thank you uh councelor
keithly next yeah thank you councelor
Appleton you mentioned that um the
applicant had come up with a new flood
alert system to support this application
that's what you said can you just tell
me what your understanding of the
current status of the warden on site is
lot of people have local people have
objected on the basis that there should
be a warden what's your understanding of
that situation as it stands okay so um
originally I believe I mean a warden has
been on site ever since planning
permission was granted in 1974
1975 um originally they were um there
was 12month occupancy in a caravan unit
in 2004 an existing bill building um was
um Extended upwards um to allow for it
was originally an office and storage but
they put um living accommodation above
it and the warden moved into that and
that freed up a caravan obviously for
Holiday home use um they then got
subsequent um sorry counselor
um is I suppose ENT the question seem to
pertain to what the current situation is
and we we've got the
in there already I was trying to I was
trying I was trying to get there okay
I'll try and come straight to the point
then
um so the warden was the the main reason
the warden was allowed to stay on site
was because he had a central role in
flood evacuation um now I think that
presented a problem when it came to this
application which is why the application
was changed and we got a new flood
strategy which effectively removes the
need for a warden um using a text and
email alert system system um I
understand that uh the
warden's accommodation was occupied
until earlier this year and then they
abruptly
left um I'm and as as I say I don't I'm
not sure what the flood evacuation plan
yeah thank you for that thank you thank
you um any further questions no which
case oh last second councelor rander
thank you chair um thank you counselor
um can you just clarify for me um the
rationale behind um no longer requiring
a warden simply because they're
permanent is it to do with the tethering
the the floats I mean what's your
understanding of
that I confess we we're not entirely on
board with the idea that they don't need
a warden we probably think that they do
um I'm probably not the best person to
ask the question actually on that on
that basis okay thank you thank you okay
uh doesn't look like we've got any
further questions in which case thank
you very much for your
contribution right we now move on to our
next speaker who is Andy Murphy agent
for the
application good evening Mr Murphy um so
uh same principle you've got three
minutes um button on the right hand side
to turn the microphone on and I'm happy
to give you a 30 second warning uh
before your time's up thank you
chairman I represent aan Estates limited
who is the owner of welfare Chase
Caravan site which is a park home site
with 28 Caravans occupied on a permanent
basis from the 1970s to about 2015 the
site was occupied by holiday Caravans
and a warden's house was built there in
2010 to assist with the site
management however a certificate of
lawfulness granted in 2014 confirmed
that the site may be occupied all year
round accordingly in 2015 the site was
redeveloped and advertised ized as a
permanently occupied Park home site and
the grounds are managed remotely from
head office in Stratford upon
aen therefore it is no longer necessary
for a warden's house to be occupied by
someone whose sole employment is at
welfare chase the deletion of condition
two will enable anyone to live there
furthermore it is desirable to ensure
the house is occupied in order to
safeguard the character and appearance
of the area an empty house is contrary
to policy cs20
there will be no difference to travel
patterns and no impact on flood risk the
safety of residents of welfare cha
Caravan site during times of flood is
secured by the latest version of the
flood risk management plan the dynamic
of managing flood risk is now different
given there are permanent residents on
the site rather than transient holiday
makers mobile phone availability and
flood warning technology has changed
since 2010
an on-site Warden is not needed to
manage to manage flood risk instead the
overall responsibility for managing
flood risk lies with an operations
director at Avan Estates Limited in
statford upon aen who is in direct
communication with the environment
agency and with residents via email text
phone call and in person if
necessary all residents have access to
an evacuation plan which involves moving
to higher land on binton Road or the
adjacent Railway
embankment the environment agency has
been consulted regarding this flood risk
management plan and they have no
objection should the park change back to
a holiday site which is very unlikely
then a legal agreement will ensure that
one of the Caravans is occupied by a
warden therefore I ask you to support
the officer recommendation and Grant
planning permission thank
you thank you very much while within
your time members do we have any
questions cast
pton thank you chair just to uh couple
of questions first of all is there any
age restriction in terms of occupation
of the site some Park home sites are
over 60 over 55 what operates at this
site I'm not aware of any age
restriction there's no restriction by
plan and condition so it's open to
anyone thank you
um second question you the you refer to
the uh aan estate Ops director and
indeed the uh the uh the officer report
at page
14 refers to the Ops director oblique
oblique Grand team uh being able to
knock on every door to let residents
know um in in the in the circumstances
of an immediate
evacuation um are you able to tell me
where
physically the Ops director is
located both in terms of are they based
at a Estates in in wood and Wen and
where when he's not in the office he or
she where where are they and similarly
with the grand team so well how how
immediate is the the opportunity to help
Evacuate the site well I the operations
director at the moment is a someone
called Mr Austin I don't know where his
where his home address is all I can say
is that the business as a whole is based
in Stratford Pon aen it's the same Riv
it's the river Aven a Estates har a
caravan SES already on the river aen in
flood risk zones they are used to
dealing with flood risk and they have
excellent access to information I just
don't know where Mr Austin lives no I
think it's just trying to understand
this question of immediate access and
and clearly that's something the officer
clear from the applicant and as the
agent for the applicant I was hoping
you'd help be able to help me with that
but okay um just the uh a final question
just for my
clarity in essence the flood risk the
flood plan now is that you sign up to
the environment agency alert
system that's correct even Estates do
and also the residents are encouraged to
do so but there is but that that's it
there is there's nothing else in it's
it's it's what you you or I could do
that is correct yes that that's that's
fine thank you okay thank you councilor
Harvey Mr mury can I simple
straightforward question this and I
think the answer is yes right um I think
you said that uh the flood risk
management plan is made available to all
residents on on the site can you just
confirm that they I presume they receive
a copy physically and I presume they
have to acknowledge that they've got it
so that you're aware that they're
informed of what the the plan actually
is is that correct that that is correct
yes it's a 23-page document I've I've
got one page here which is the flowchart
so physically given to them they know
what it is and because they're permanent
residents they are incentivized to to
read it and learn about it and
communicate with AV Estates if they have
any
questions any further questions for the
agent no in which case thank you very
much for your
contribution we move on then to our
final speaker who is the W member
councelor
perella good evening counselor uh so
you've got five minutes I'm happy to
give you a 30 second warning um
otherwise when you're ready take it
away thank you chair good evening
members the dwelling was given
permission because of it being the
warden dwelling with the current
occupation restriction otherwise we can
assume that a new dwelling would not
have been given permission at this
location the site lies outside a builda
par boundary of well for Donavon in open
Countryside and it's in flood zone 3B
the functional flood plane the
application states that there isn't a
need for a warden anymore but residents
think otherwise the location in flood
zone 3 is vulnerable to flooding
episodes and with a climate emergency
and storms these episodes are going to
be more regular the warden was
responsible for implementing the flood
evacuation management plan the condition
to safeguard the dwelling for a warden
was and is not only reasonable able but
necessary to ask residents to rely on
automated messages and texts from the
environment agency for a flood
evacuation plan is not acceptable when
you leave in flood zone 3B members under
current planning policy residential
dwelling such as these will not be
approved without the word and only
condition therefore to remove the
condition is highly inappropriate to
then propose a s 106 condition for
another warding accom Warden
accommodation when there is already a w
and dwelling on the site which is the
subject of this variation seems to me to
be
absurd whether the site is composed of
permanent residencies is not a planning
matter however planning policies
material for this application at as it
is a planning variation so open
Countryside build up area boundary and
flood plane considerations do apply the
planning application is contrary to our
neighbor development plan policy h 9
flood risk and
hl7 Caravan sites it is contrary to core
strategy policy as10 Countryside and
Villages it is also contrary to policy
CS4 water environment and flood risk and
I will quote from that land use in high
probability flood zone 3B should be
restricted to water compatible or with
the exception test to essential
infrastructure the warden house would
have been essential infrastructure for
the site thank
you thank you very much um members do we
have any questions for our war
member Council keithy thank you chair
good evening counselor um thank you for
that I asked a previous um councelor of
wford Parish what the current situation
is with the warden on site and he
thought that there hadn't been a warden
since the beginning of the year so I'm
assuming that property is actually empty
is that your understanding I'm I'm not
aware of that uh maybe the agent will
be I'm not okay so at the moment
potentially we just have an empty empty
dwelling on the site is is what I'm
thinking okay
thanks counc Harvey yes counselor
um planning committee has before uh in
various cases being presented with
assertions by speakers and and have to
take that into account you've made an
assertion that residents think otherwise
in relation to the need for a
warden rather than just assert can you
provide data and evidence that would
substantiate that assertion
please yeah so obviously there there are
comments on the learning portal from
residents um that you know they they
came to the site with you know knowing
that there was a warden on site which is
very important when you leave on on a
flood plane the parish council also uh
consider uh and and myself consider the
um presence of a warden
important um and at the moment the
condition for the warden was this house
this this dwelling which otherwise would
not have been given uh planning
permission so my point is that if you
know it's they shouldn't rely on text
and alerts from the environment agency
there should be a warden there as they
were before which can implement the
flood evacuation plan especially for
those elderly residents on site so it's
it's actually an issue of safety for me
thank
you chairman I take it the answer to the
question therefore is no thank
you I might actually ask a question
myself just for um clarity's sake when
referring to Residents do you mean
residents of the park itself or the
village yes residents of w for Chase
okay thank you any further questions for
our W
member no in which case thank you very
much for your contribution
right uh we now move on then to points
of clarification from our officers do we
have any what clarification yes
councelor Harvey um thank you chairman
the diagram on page
21 shows the site with a boundary marked
to
it in relation to
as10 and the importance of as10 what is
the significance of that boundary in
other words is the the site that we're
talking about is it within the developed
site therefore as10 doesn't apply
doesn't isn't relevant or or what is the
status of that line that property and
as10
please thank you so um that outline
which is similar to the outline on on
the slide is the red line development
boundary for the 2009 planning
application um the site is away from the
built-up area boundary of wford so it's
within Open Country Side location um and
core strategy policy as10 applies to the
whole site because it's outside of the
built of perer boundary so the red line
on the plan and in the report isn't the
built of perer boundary it's it's the
development
site any followup counc Harvey or we
okay
I'm still left that's fine I understand
that what I'm struggling with now is
what's the significance of that of that
red line in relation to property which
is already
built are we talking about a replacement
like a
replacement um or are we talking about
this could be a green field site and
this happens to be an application for a
house in the open Countryside that's
what I'm struggling with at the moment
so the the line um relates to the area
the lawful area for the for the um
residential units and the Caravans
that's the same red line as which the
appeal decision established the all year
round occupation um we're still in the
open Countryside and the dwelling is
already there um it's it's just seeking
to remove the condition for the warden's
dwelling does that
help yes thank
you
any further points of clarification
councilor keatley thanks chair yes um if
I could ask the case office I'm on page
15 as well um the question I suppose
I've got is you you've um you've
summarized you've summarized the um your
assessment of the need for a warden
under the flood risk management plan and
you've come to the conclusion that
you're satisfied that there's no longer
a need and that's at odds with what
we're hearing from
objectors my question really is is is
the provision of a warden I don't think
it's a planning issue well I be right
more likely to be a site licensing issue
and do you know if there's any legal
obligation that that would um support
the assertions of the objectors that
they feel that for these 28
dwellings that there must be a site
flood Warden does that make sense you
you've you've come to the conclusion
that you don't think there needs to be
one because of the flood risk management
plan but everyone's telling us they
think in objecting they're telling us
that they think there should be one and
for 28 dwellings because there's such a
high risk on flood zone B this a site
licensing issue do you know if there's
any legislation that would would would
help us understand whether or not in
fact there ought to be some
consideration for
this so each application is assessed on
its own merits and the 2009 planning
application and the previous
applications established the law for
right for a warden's dwelling on site um
this application is seeking to remove
that
um we've had the amended flood risk um
evacuation management plan which
outlines the new evacuation process and
includes um a set strategy for emails
and texts and also for the Ops director
to be on site knocking in um where
evacuation is required so I do feel that
in light of the changes of the site um
the as outlined in the report the
removal of the there is no longer a
functional need for Warden
onsite just in a very quick followup on
that did did the sort of fire and rescue
service comment on on that flood risk
assessment the management plan that you
you've
considered I did send them the report
and they came back with no
comment thank you councelor pton next
thank you chair to assist councelor
Harvey um are you able without giving
any private information away able to
give any indication in terms of the
representations
made um there were six note one was from
CPR so there were five
representations how many of those were
residents of this site are you able to
help us with that in terms of dat uh
counselor's councelor Harvey's request
for
data I would have to go through and
check check the addresses but um we
would still afford the comments of
objection the same amount of weight
whether or not they lived on the site or
not I understand that but I think um I
think councelor Harvey was particularly
concerned about uh whether the level of
objections were by residents and I'm
comfortable with waiting a couple of
minutes we're already P the chair's
personal best of eight minutes so
there's
no well I do try um I'm happy for for
you to to look into it to sort of have a
have an indicative um approach that but
yes I think it is worth noting that as
as noted um all responses are
are equal um but yes I'm happy if you
did want to um have a quick look and
find out an indication of whether they
are on the site or not in the meantime
do we have any other points of
clarification for
officers cvey request request for
information um in answer to the
question uh about the frequency of
flooding the the answer given was 2007
2010 20 13 I think um is that a good
representation of the frequency with
which this site
floods I'm trying to I'm trying to
assess the risk that's involved
here um the flood risk evacuation plan
outlines that there's a medium risk each
year that has a chance of flooding
between 1 and
3.3% um that takes into account the
effect of any flood defenses in the area
and I've read that from page eight of
the flood risk evacuation management
plan
strategy C Keithley another question
thank you chair this really relates to
my questions to um the parish council
about the warden on site whether or not
that property is vacant did the
applicant give you any data or
information about
that unfortunately I don't know whether
or not it is it is vacant currently
okay
thanks okay any further points of
clarification you want to come in on
that so in addition to the comments from
C CPR there were six um comments from um
occupiers of welfare Chase different
numbers but they all had a welfare Chase
address thank
you okay thank you um any further points
clarification councilor
rander thank you um can I just Sheck do
you know anything about in the flood
risk plan about the time required for
the Ops Team to be on
site is that any aspect of that there's
quite a lot of mention that people will
be on site but we haven't established
where they're located where they're
traveling from so is there a requirement
in that for them to be able to arrive
within a certain period of time um so
there's no requirement that I've seen
within the within the plan that they
should arrive within a certain amount of
time um I have received a clarification
via email that the Ops director and
ground team will be based at the head
office um and that's on the W Road in
Stratford um and I believe that's about
a um just bear with me about a 15 or 20
minute driveway um and if there were a
flooding
incident would that impact on their
ability to arrive at the
site the flood uh risk evacuation man M
plan does outline that the leading time
for flu feding of the river Avent is
quite long EG several hours to several
days therefore the environment agency
are able to provide flood warnings in
excess of two hours and flood alerts may
be issued up to 36 hours in advance
based on forecast models um within
within the strategy there are also
certain levels um to which um which
triggers which response would be um had
um and it's level three um where the Ops
director and ground team would knock on
every door to let residents know um I
don't have the time levels but I do know
the that the triggers would be for the
environment agency flood warnings um Met
Office weather warnings for heavy rain
in force reports of significant flooding
and disruption of the community in the
in the media and AFL reports to level
three does that answer yes thank
you thank you any further points of
clarification I have one very quick one
um before we move to the debate um now
one one point was made I can't remember
which speaker but uh with regards to any
agreement um with me residents of this
site um to have the ward a warden in
situ I'm I right in understanding that
that would be a private civil matter and
has no uh grounds within the planning um
structure as it
were I'm aware that the the only
restriction in terms of planning is is
the condition that which this is seeking
to remove outside of that I'm not aware
of any other requirement for a warden to
be on site great thank you very much uh
in which case we can move to debate um
who would like to
start and we jump at once councilor
Pon I feel like Mario
batell um
okay um in terms of cancel arander
basically uh this is a site get that
gets wet very quickly you know oh sorry
when when when there is flooding where
the rivers up it gets wet it is also
true to say that the location and the
nature of how the aen floods in that
particular part of the world um is such
that the environment agency is able to
give significant warnings it is not a
site um that is prone to a flash flow BL
in that sense historically that's no
guarantee of the future but historically
it's not been a site where people are in
a dated within 15
minutes
um and uh but having said that
um currently the site
occupiers enjoy the benefit of a warden
which is uh or have historically
involved enjoyed the benefit of a warden
onsite which G gives an additional level
level of robustness to the evacuation
plan for the site um it is Reliant now
upon everything that we all rely upon
which is the the text messaging service
from EA plus the proximity of aan estate
staff to get
there um I'm not despite my discomfort
about it able to find a planning reason
to hang my hat on that what we do have
however is a property
that under our current policies would
not be afforded permission for a
dwelling house if none existed on that
at that particular site it's INF flood
zone 3B it's outside the builtup area
boundary and in essence what we
have what overcame that was what might
be termed a set of very special
circumstances eg a Warden being on
site if there's a if there's a
functional if there's no functional need
for a warden and this is not a site that
we would ordinarily Grant planning
permission for permanent
occupation um I'm struggling to see why
we should then ignore everything that
we've done thus far about planning
history of the site and say that it's
okay in terms of a residential
property um and I I I I need to be
convinced that it is not um a site where
as the officer has raised um it's in
contravention the officer does
acknowledge that
as10
yes yeah
as10 um cs15 cs16 and the the
neighborhood development plan shouldn't
be brought into into play here and
bluntly if the fullback position if it's
a park home well
okay I I I I I I I I'll wait to hear
what other members of the committee have
got to say um but I am struggling on
those basis on that basis to to support
officers but I will listen to what
others have got to say thank you
councilor pemon um I'll just point out
at this point the the the fullback
position in the officer report has been
accepted as valid and so so uh if
members were minded to suggest otherwise
they would have to have a reason to
invalidate that that assessment I'm not
going down that route that's fine I just
thought I'd make it clear uh councelor
Keithley thanks chair
um okay uh well I live right alongside
the river Oden so I know exactly how
quickly it comes up um not very quickly
actually you normally have quite a bit
of time and you can see it coming
there's plenty of warning and I know the
Welford site very well as well um
so I think that uh what's in my mind is
that we probably got an empty dwelling
at the moment fact is uh you don't
really need to employ a flood warning a
flood Warden on a site of 28 homes when
you've got potentially 36 hours to know
that you potentially got a problem so
from what I've
gleaned in my questioning I think we've
got an empty
dwelling not one that's occupied by a
flood warden so in fact the argument
that the site must have a flood
Warden I I have to really set aside
because there isn't one there now as far
as I can see so if there was a flood
like there was just the other week
um I won't go into detail about why I
know there was a flood the other week
but there was and the river came up very
high over our log um the people there
would have had to sort themselves out
anyway because there isn't a flood
Warden to go around knocking on the door
so at the moment relying on the ops
manager or the texts or whatever else
they're getting from the Met Office so I
think the argument that um there has to
be a flood War Warden is is uh doesn't
carry for me a huge amount of weight so
then then you look at right got an empty
dwelling what do we do with an empty
dwelling do do we allow them to uh to
vary the conditions so that somebody can
live in it or do we say that it's got to
be knocked down and something else put
in its place and if something else put
in this place as a park home then what
we read in the report is actually that's
worse than what we've got now because
it'll it'll have a greater impact on
flood resilience of the site so in my
mind I feel that we we can't find I
can't find a reason to go against the
officer's recommendation so I'd make a
proposal that we go with the officer's
recommendation thank you very much
councelor
Keithley um I you actually ated my
thoughts on this quite succinctly um I
think it's for my part I the issue is
that we've got a development on a flood
plane unfortunately that dates back to
1975 and so this committee now is not
really in a position to contend uh that
point um would anyone else like to
contribute to the
debate C Harvey I'd like to Second
Council Keith Le's proposal thank you
very
much okay um um if no one else is um
jumping to speak uh we've had a proposal
and a second to
um yes yeah yeah pardon me two
SEC pardon me okay so uh we've had a
proposal has been seconded to uh Grant
the application um subject to the
section 106 agreement um as is noted in
the update sheet can I see all those in
favor
please unanimous chair
Noor okay um in which case
uh um Council uh sorry committee
resolves to Grant application
SLV subject to one section 106
agreement all right thank you
everyone we now move on then to our
final application of this evening which
is application
3F the Dutch Barn Glee Farm Exel
olster our presenting officer is Sarah
Floy and when you're ready uh feel free
to take it
away
thank you
chairman the application site is located
on the edge of the village of EX
the site is located within the
conservation area boundary as indicated
by the pink line on this plan I'll just
highlight that for you you can see my
curse oh
sorry by this pink line here which goes
around the application
site the red structures on the plan
indicate nearby listed buildings the
site's also within the Arden special
landscape area and a public footpath AB
buts the northeastern boundary of the
site and is seen running along
here here we see a satellite image of
the village with the application site
located
here this is a full planning application
for the conversion of a Dutch Barn into
one dwelling here we see the proposed
site plan the dwelling would have four
bedrooms and would rely on an existing
access which runs up here this would be
the Garden area and there's a area of
parking proposed
here here we see the proposed elevations
of the dwelling the application proposes
new fenestration on all elevations with
a flu seen here as
well this image is taking taken facing
south and shows the existing Dutch barn
and lean
to this image is taken fa from the
public footpath facing the Northwest and
shows the rear of the barn the Garden
area will be located over here behind
the
vegetation this final image is taken
facing Southwest with the public
footpath entrance and location
here the nearest neighboring dwelling
known as owl's end is just behind the
tree
here chairman the principle of
development is unacceptable with the
proposal being contrary to policy cs15
and as10 as the site is located outside
of the physical confines of the village
and the barn is not constructed of brick
or stone or of any architectural Merit a
previous application in 2022 for the
conversion of the barn to a dwelling was
refused us used the subsequent appeal
was dismissed in February this year with
the inspector upholding this in
principal reason for refusal the
permission for the conversion of the
barn to a holiday La was granted in May
this year however this is not considered
a former fullback possession as officers
consider it would be not it would not be
more harmful than what is proposed under
this application the recommendation is
therefore to refuse the application for
the reason detailed on page 46 of the
agenda and the updates in the update
sheet thank you thanks very much Sarah
okay um our first Speaker this evening
is Jake collinge agent for the
application um I'll note at this point I
also have Julia Hall um registered to
speak but I understand that for the
purpose of splitting time it was just Mr
Collin who was speaking at this
time okay no worries at
all good evening uh so you've got three
minutes and um I'm happy to give you a
30 second warning uh before your 's up
otherwise um it's the button on the
right hand side to turn the app
microphone on and when you're ready take
it
away chairman members of the committee
can I thank you for the opportunity of
addressing you this evening it will not
be lost on you that the application has
significant local support and no
objection from any technical consult te
indeed the acceptability of the scheme
rests on only one matter and that is
whether or not the building is located
within the physical confines of
all that is a matter in relation to
which you as counselors are entitled to
exercise your own
judgment for my part I have always held
the view that the building located
adjacent to the Parish church and with a
close physical and visual relationship
with the residential buildings at Glee
Farm Falls within the physical confines
of
exor I recognize that that is not a view
that is shared by your officers or the
previous appeal inspector who app that
the building does not have
characteristics of a village location
but instead reads as part of the open
Countryside
Beyond however and whilst I disagree
with the inspector there has been a
material and highly significant change
of circumstances since that appeal
decision planning permission has now
been granted for the conversion of the
building to Holiday let accommodation
with parking and residential amenity
space to the south in physical terms the
proposed scheme is identical to the
approved scheme
scheme the consequence of the permission
is that the building and use the
surrounding land would now have accepted
residential characteristics that would
most definitely align the building with
the character of residential uses and
activities within the village that is no
longer would the building readed part of
the open Countryside as the inspector
suggested rather it would furtherance a
clear and close physical relationship
within the confines of the
village for these reasons I would invite
you to con know that the building is
within the physical confines of exol if
you do there is no policy impediment to
the grant of planning
permission to assist you further in this
regard it is material to note that the
adjacent buildings at Glee Farm which
are only 7 MERS from the Dutch bar have
been held by your officers to fall
within the physical confines of the
village and significantly planning
permission was granted in 2020 to
convert six of these from holiday LS to
permanent dwellings
all of the forgoing Allied to the
significant local support from the
parish council and local residents who
recognize the value of permanent
residential occupation to the
sustainability and composition of the
local community will I hope persuade you
of this to support this application
thank
you thank you very much well within your
time members to um sorry at this point
I'll I'll ask um there's a couple of
seconds left um M Hall did you want to
come up just in case there are any
questions to you as a supporter of the
application as well thank you um members
do we have any questions for our agent
or support this
evening C
Keithley yeah thank thank you chair um
thank you Mr colling
um I'm wondering if you can help me
answer a question about the number of
holiday lets in Exel because I've read
in the report there's a
lot how many of those those are within
the builtup area of EX all and how many
are
outside I have to say that's almost an
impossible question for me to answer if
only because there is no definition of
the built up area of EX all it's a
matter of judgment as to whether or not
individual properties lie within or
outside the um the physical confines of
the village but there's no definitive
line so I can't tell you which ones are
within that line and which ones are
outside but
okay thank you very much thank
you any further questions for our
supporter or
agent no uh in which case thank you both
very
much sorry to bring you forward off that
basis okay um we now move on then to our
final speaker who is W member councelor
Stanley good evening
counselor so yes you've got five minutes
I'm happy to give you a 30 second
warning as well um otherwise once you're
Inu take it
away thank you chair members I'm here
today to explain to you why I am in full
support of this application and why you
should look to Grant this application
tonight this application already has
planning approved for the conversion of
This deric Barn to be turned into a
holiday let so members the principle of
having a dwelling here is not the issue
it is for what it was is to be used as I
set out the following reasons which
explain why the conversion of This Barn
into a residential dwelling should be
granted as10 is of utmost importance for
this application and this is where
weight should be applied as10 States all
proposals will be thoroughly assessed
against the principles of of sustainable
development including the need to
minimize impact on the occupiers and
users of existing properties in the area
avoid a level of increase in traffic on
Rural roads that would be harmful to the
local area and prioritize the ReUse of
Brownfield land and existing buildings
as a residential use property this
conversion will minimize its impact on
occupiers and users of existing
properties in the area than if it were
to be a holiday let there would
naturally be less cars on the rural
roads of exhall should it be granted
appr approval as residential use this
application would also help to avoid a
level of increase in traffic for the
above points also by allowing its use is
residential this is prioritizing the
ReUse of this existing building in a
beneficial way to the Village as well as
the district as10 also States under
residential part SE that the conversion
to a res to a residential use of a
building within the physical confines of
a village there is no question that this
site sits sits within the physical
confines of the village of exhall if you
look at the image on the screen um this
evening it shows aligned boundary for
the conservation area which Circle which
arrowed sorry is where the barn sits no
one has been able to supply me with the
evidence to believe otherwise and being
a local and knowing the layer of the
land trust me when I say a building
could not be closer to other buildings
within a the physical confines of a
village within the temp temple Gren exor
2021 Parish plan it also states that
policy as10 as of the core strategy also
supports other types of development
where it would would help support the
rural community or rural economy this
above statement also shows that the
parish would benefit from this
development cs1 states that the council
support and will apply the principle
that planning to secure a high quality
environment managed economic growth and
social Equity are of equal importance
all development proposal should
contribute towards the character and
quality of the district and the
well-being of those who live and work in
and visit the district development
should contribute towards the
maintenance of sustainable communities
within the district by developing this
old redundant Barn it will contribute to
the character and quality of the
district by bringing a building back
into use a residential delling will be
able to contribute towards Village Life
for more far more than a holiday home
leading to a sustainable Community
having spoken with immediate neighbors
it will benefit their well-being as they
may want as they want this Barn to be
for residential use the office officer
refers to the 2 03 housing needs survey
in their report this survey was
completed 20 years ago it should hold no
weight in deciding to not Grant this
application tonight what was needed 20
years ago is a lot different to what is
needed in this District in
2023 from speaking with residents they
have also informed me that exall has
about 50 homes for residents and already
has about 16 holiday lets within this
number it's a small community with a
church and a village hall as their only
Community spaces and they use these
spaces to bring villagers together to
prevent isolation and support their
mental health these spaces are used to
run fundraising events which require
Village support the residents feel they
need more villagers to get involved and
take an active role they have been
unable to recruit their members onto the
Village Hall committee for several years
and with fewer residents they fear it
will be unsustainable previous planning
decisions have allowed adjacent
properties to be converted into single
larger ones thus reducing the number of
residents the residents feel that good
planning should be creating viable
healthy communities and not reducing
them to to size to a size that just
doesn't work and in conclusion this
property would be ideal for a family who
could contribute to the Village Way of
Life this application complies with CS4
water and environment flood risk the
application complies with cs8 historic
environment of the core strategy so in
conclusion members there is as always a
planning balance here we have a property
and design of which is quite acceptable
to a planning as a holiday let this
application is to change that use to a
permanent dwelling I suggest that this
is a reasonable and Pate change
benefiting the community at large thank
you thank you councelor well within your
time uh members do we have any questions
K Pon thank you chair can I just I
didn't quite catch um I caught 50
residents but I didn't catch the number
of holiday lets So speaking with
residents they've told me that there's
there about 50 homes within X Hall and
already about 16 of those holiday that's
yeah okay so about
30% about 30% of the of the of the
properties are holiday
lets any further questions counc Keith
yeah thank you chair good evening
councelor Stanley
um in your statement you
mentioned uh I'm on page 39 of the
report actually because your statement
is here you say that as residential use
property this conversion minimizes the
impact on occupiers and uses of existing
properties in the area because naturally
there would be less cars you
say um if it was not granted if if it
should it be granted
residential I'm I'm interested in that
because I
think if it was permanently occupied
you'd have family there you'd have
deliveries coming toing throwing School
runs 24 4 7
365 was a holiday L you wouldn't have
the same amount of activity so I'm just
interested in how you could conclude
that in fact as a holiday La there'd be
less cars than there would if it was a
permanent
dwelling I believe there'd be less cars
purely because as a holiday L an average
turnover is 3 days for someone to stay
in that accommodation um and if it was a
four bed you could have up to four cars
using that to get to get to the Village
so more more cars on the road every 3
days you'd then have to have a cleaner
to come to that site to clean a delivery
van to deliver Goods um and as as a as a
home as somebody's home you know they
they could possibly work from home you
don't know what the circumstances would
be so they wouldn't be doing school run
sorry they wouldn't be commuting as it
were they'd be on be working from home
and they I I I personally believe that
as as a as a home it would be of benefit
to the residents of of of
EXO any further questions for our war
member very quick very quick quick
question councelor s just s follow up on
that previous one we've heard that 30%
of the property ex all are holiday lets
so assuming that all these holiday lets
got converted to permanent homes to be a
lot less traffic in Exel would that be
the case in your
view I'd thought so because you'd have
people have to you have to drive to
exhall so depending on what the size of
the holiday lets are um you know it
depends on because it depends on who who
goes and uses them I can't I can't I
can't tell you how many yeah yeah thank
you thank you okay um I think that's for
questions from Members thank you very
much okay we can now move on then to
points of clarification for officers do
we have any councelor
lwood uh thank you thank you chair um
yes um to me I'm confused
about whether this is within the village
or not it's within as I've heard it's
within the conservation area there isn't
a boab here presumably or or any formal
um line drawn on a map to determine what
the center of what what belongs to the
Village or not so how have you concluded
it is not part of the village as we've
heard the other uh buildings Within in
the village are less than seven meters
away thank you I'll touch on your first
the first part of your question first so
there isn't a vot of area boundary for
exol it's an all other settlement so
it's the physical confines assessment is
what we have to go with which is
obviously a matter of planning judgement
I'd refer you to the appeal statement
sorry the appeal decision for the
previous application for the conversion
of the building to a dwelling where the
inspector said the following I
acknowledge that the appeal building is
located within the conservation area and
his historically the building is likely
to have had a functional relationship
with the former GLE Farmstead so this is
the GLE Farmhouse if you can see my
mouse and then these are the barns that
were associated with it
here however I find that the appal
building's physical separation from the
former farm buildings means that it is
not viewed in the context of the cluster
of buildings it appears as a separate
building in the rural landscape and is
physically segregated from the
prevailing pattern of development within
the village so that was specific spe Al
on the conservation area point but the
inspector said it was clearly separated
from these
buildings which with the access track
which is seen here detaching it from
these
buildings it exists as a sporadic form
of development within a spacious rural
setting I think they're referring to it
being within this field
here and it's not physically joins the
existing Urban Development and reads as
part of the countryside
Beyond
off sorry I just say officers concur
with that assessment of the
inspector thank you any further points
clarification coun Harvey can I just
pursue on that that last Point
um the the Crux of this seems to me to
be the the appeal
decision
and to what extent were you did you feel
Bound by that decision or to what extent
did you feel able to to your own
conclusion about the proximity and the
relationship so I was also the officer
for the appeal scheme and my assessment
in the de delegated report was that it
was not within the fiscal confines and
then the inspector subsequently agree
with that assessment so I'm my
assessment of this application is in
line with my previous assessment but the
inspector also sort of concurred with
that I believe I had Council passing him
next uh can you tell me what are the
planning reasons for it being acceptable
as a holiday let but not as a um a
dwelling of course sorry so cs24
supports holiday Els in appropriate
locations and as10 S also supports
holiday lets where they're considered
appropriate so the principal of
development is supported by two separate
policies whereas the conversion to a
dwelling is is not supported by as10 or
cs-15
councilor
pton thank you in coming to that policy
consideration around holiday lets to
what extent if any did the officer
consider the volume of holiday lets
already in existence in EXL um there
is this would not be Alan in communities
where the airb andb effect and and I and
I I do take issue with I I do have a
different view to councelor Keithley
about traffic movements with Airbnb
holid type properties so uh I'm aware we
do not currently have an Airbnb policy
per se but the question around
permissioning a holiday El whether is
already a substantial number of holiday
lets in a small community and its impact
on sustainability to what extent if at
all did that come into play in that
original
decision um I recall discussing it with
my manager at the time and I remember
looking through our system of
applications and identifying that there
was an application for three holiday
lets in the village which was quite
recent and then I found two other
separate applications for holiday lights
so that was a total of five holiday
lights I personally found permission for
within the village there may be other
Holiday Lights operating as Airbnb which
haven't been granted permission I did do
a bit of research into that but I wasn't
able personally to find any other
properties so it was taken into
consideration to answer your question so
just follow up that so what we have from
your research is a minimum range of
10% uh up to a range of
30% holiday letter ble Airbnb in what is
in all other settlements uh and by
definition so I'm would I be correcting
that that given what the ward memb said
and what you've said that seem to be the
range anecdotally yes it's it's hard to
give aens answer I I I well I think
you're certainly you've done some
research I I accept that the upper limit
might be more
anecdotal okay thank you any further
points of clarification counc Keithley
thank you chair just a quick one to the
case officer um we heard that there was
a village
church and something else a village hall
and a church do you know if there's a a
shop or other facilities all or where
the closest facilities are if there
isn't I'm not aware that there are the
facilities in the village I believe
wixford is the closest settlement with
facilities thank you okay thanks um any
further points clarification no in which
case we can move to debate who would
like to
start start picking on
someone CLE Harvey quite happy to go
first the Crux of this seems to me to be
um the relatively recent appeal
decision I I was interested in the
officers um answer to my question that
she came to she in relation to the
previous application she had come to her
own decision about proximity and whether
it was within the confines of the
village or not and to find that we are
presented with an inspector's decision
his assessment that concurs with that
um added to which
the barn is not made of either stone or
brick and it doesn't have apparently it
doesn't have any AR particular
architectural
Merit um I really can't see any good
reason for good planning reason for not
agreeing with the officers
recommendation despite the assertions
the views of local Villages that we've
heard a expressed by councelor Stanley
um I still can't get away from the the
conclusion that um not only are
we we have to take account of the
inspector's decision and his rationale
for his decision and I can't see that
there are material changes which cause
causes me to come to a different
conclusion
so I'm I'm happy to go along with with
the officer's recommendation to
refuse is that a proposal councelor yes
it is thank you uh go councelor Eden
next thank you chair um very much
echoing councel Harvey's um points there
um the consistency in the way that we've
treated this as officers and then uh the
inspector backing that up um the fact
that it doesn't align all this type of
development doesn't align with our
policies at all of as10 cs15 I'm I won't
waffle on I'll instead just second
councelor Harvey's
proposal thank you I believe got councel
pton
next thank you um I'm going to support
the officer's recommendation having
listened to everything um but I would
wish to make a comment I think that we
have in cons in the consideration of the
holiday let I understand it's a
different policy
framework I do think we have created by
doing so an anomaly here I also think
that uh and this is again perhaps laying
some kind of marker down even at
10% um in terms of sustainable
communities of this nature or the
sustainability of communities of this
nature 10% holiday let come airb andb is
to too high and certainly if it were
anywhere near 30% it's too high and I
think that we do need to be thinking
more closely about the impact of such
properties particularly on smaller rural
communities um I'm not entirely
convinced that had an inspector seen
this that they would would would
actually have followed on from and
allowed it I think they would have taken
a similar view that any residential or
you know temp temporary residential
property here would have been I think
the principle that it shouldn't have
been built as a as resi in the first
place should have read through to a
holiday let application I I understand
and I do follow that it's a different
policy context but I think it's created
an anomaly I also think we we need to
start to think more closely about the
impact of um holiday lets economy versus
sustainability particularly for our
smaller community so I I really just
make that as an observation uh and
perhaps that to be sort of you know into
the hopper and I I I know the head of
head of services here uh for for future
reference having said all of that I find
myself in a position where I have a lot
of sympathy with the
applicant I think I understand
technically but I think it's it is a
fine line as to whether it's actually
part of Exel or not but on balance I
will be supporting off officers for this
particular
one thank you councelor and uh thank you
for airing that note uh councelor H
serapan um yes I think that the decision
if it was brick or stone and had some uh
architectural
Merit uh there wouldn't be a problem
with the residential property and um I
shall go with the officer's
recommendation on this one thank you
councelor Keithley yes thanks
um I'm not sure I agree with um
councelor pton when he says this is an
anomaly but what I do agree with
councilor pmon is that we've allowed a
lot of holiday lets to be permitted
through our policies in this very small
village which is unsustainable has got
no facilities if we're not careful we
could end up with a Holiday
Village um and I think that would be um
a big mistake so that's something I do
agree with councilor pton of I don't
actually like the fact we looking at an
appeal decision that's very recent it
feels like we're going around the loop
with the applicant trying to
circumnavigate planning to uh having
been refused to permanent residence in
the first place come back to get a
holiday Le through the policy and now is
trying to get permanent residence again
um I I don't agree with that um I'm
concerned actually about setting a
president for the conversion of a number
of other holiday accommodations into
permanent residence in exol because this
would open the floodgates potentially to
that so for all those Reasons I'm going
to be supporting the officers I'm happy
to we got a proposal already I'm happy
to Second whoever made the orig so okay
fine I'll shut up then thank you thank
you very much yeah uh well yeah there's
certainly um a view um expressed yes i'
just for my comments on the end I
looking at it on a map on a plan I can
see why the confines of the video could
be seen as being surrounding this
looking at it on site as a you know
photos and the form of structure that
we've got I think that's what's making
me come down on the side of the officers
as well uh and the inspectorate um Okay
so we've got a proposal um which has
been seconded to refuse in line with the
officer's recommendations can I see all
those in favor please un nous chair
thank you very much uh in which case
committee resolves to refuse application
F okay and item seven urgent
business no items of urgence okay which
case meeting's closed thank you very
much